I want to share this with two people one
of them my daughter Alice is waiting at
home the other one is waiting somewhere
else I hope every bit of growth that
I've had in my career especially in my
writing and in my performing came
because I met Michelle McNamara because
I met and married this woman who just
was so much so much like wiser and self
actualized and aware of life than I was
and and that I had convinced myself that
I was aware and self actualized and
mature but then I met the real deal and
so I think it's one of the reasons I
didn't prepare a speech because I was so
comfortable with you know when I
especially when I saw take special and
John mulaney's and Hannibal's and Amy
Schumer's I was just so okay with going
oh there's people that are in my life
that helped me to aspire to something
and to evolve to something better and
I'm just lucky to get to have that in my
life so to have that ripped out of my
life the way that it has this year I'm
not trying to say that this is
meaningless but it really does
everything seems like the lights have
been turned down 50% on everything since
she's gone you know it's just going to
be a long long time before I can be the
kind of person that she made me again